le Conseil Général de la Réunion vous
présente lien social le Conseil général
au côté des
Réunionnais toute petite elle a toujours
été toujours souriant toujours
débrouillard toujours vouloir faire plus
toujours vouloir faire plaisir à maman
ou à sa sœur
elle avait des résultats bien audessus
de de autes
camarades et je peux même dire que
c'était bien ma meilleure élève elle
tournait autour de 18 19 de moyenne
toute l'année en 10 ans de primaire je
n'ai pas vu beaucoup d'élèves aussi
performants c'est l'histoire d'une jeune
femme d'à peine 18 ans c'est l'histoire
d'une belle réussite scolaire sportive
artistique qui fait la fierté de son
entourage depuis des années c'est
l'histoire d'une jeune Réunionnaise
Elvina au parcours exemplaire mais un
parcours terriblement difficile car
Elvina est aveugle depuis l'âge de 11
ans parce que quand je suis quand j'ai
perdu la vue il y a quelques
annéesah je me suis dit oui bon bah
c'est fini comment construit-elle sa vie
quelle force intérieure lui permet de
réussir ce qu'elle entreprend quel
exemple donnet-elle à la société
réunionnaise on en parle maintenant dans
lien
social Elvina est au CM2 elle fait
partie des meilleurs élèves de sa classe
très scolaire avec une forte envie
d'être la première sa vue est normale
jusqu'à l'âge de 11 ans donc le souvenir
que j'en ai c'est effectivement d'une
élève qui était très scolaire très
brillante mais qu'elle avait de plus en
plus de mal à voir et donc elle devait
s'approcher ou qu'elle devait en tout
cas mettre la feuille de plus en plus
près qu'elle baissait la tête jusqu'à
toucher pratiquement la table donc c'est
là que j'ai aler mon directeur monsieur
mon de l'époque Elvina est atteinte
d'une maladie qui affecte et détruit le
ner optique elle perd la vue en quelques
semaines c'est un glocome qu'on n pas pu
détecter à
temps voilà elle a perdu la vue très
rapidement je dirais en un mois ça été
très très rapide la nouvelle est
terrible Elvina et ses proches sont sous
le choc tout a été si rapide mais Elvina
conserve un bien très précieux une
combativité et une force de caractère
unique à 11 ans elle décide de se
laisser envahir par son handicap pour
elle elle doit continuer à vivre le plus
normalement possible et au bout d'un
moment aussi bah c'est dur de vivre sans
être autonome et de dépendre tout le
temps de tout le monde donc plus le
temps il passe et plus si on n pas
autonome ça devient dur à accepter en
fait sa maman la soutient autant qu'elle
le peut puisant sa force dans celle de
sa fille Elvina découvre les instituts
spécialisés et profite des structures
adaptées comme la médiathèque de
Sainte-Marie où elle apprend le braille
ah ben elle a vite pigé elle a vite
compris hein c'est une enfant qui qui
était très comment
dire
réceptive les enfants c'est toujours
plus facile avec eux qu' avec les
adultes en un mois seulement Elvina
apprend à lire avec ses doigts une
performance en parallèle malgré son
handicap elle continue sa scolarité dans
un collège normal elle réussit le tour
de force de faire des meilleurs élèves
pour ses professeurs Elvina est un
modèle de courage elle faisait vraiment
partie intégrante de la classe et
c'était toujours la première à répondre
ENF c'était vraiment pour moi un moteur
quoi son handicap n'était absolument pas
gênant on finissait presque par
l'oubl la réussite d'vina à l'école est
excellente mais elle veut plus après sa
3è elle décide de poursuivre ses études
en France loin des siens loin de son
pays loin de ses repères elle s'est très
vite adapté en métropole j'ai vu ça
pendant une semaine et je me
disais et ben je pense qu'elle est fait
pour rester là-bas elle entre dans une
famille d'accueil et obtient son bac
avec brio aujourd'hui elle est à
l'université elle s'est installé seule
dans un petit appartement parisien car
elle tient à garder son indépendance
j'ai toujours voulu habiter tout seule
et prendre mon indépendance donc du coup
c'est un peu tion de de d'un enin
presque un rêve quoi mais Elvina ne
s'arrête pas là elle se fixe de nouveaux
défis elle fait du sport de haut niveau
et participe à des compétitions avec des
résultats impressionnants réussite
scolaire exemplaire réussite sportive
tout aussi exemplaire elle est en plus
passionnée de musique elle joue de la
guitare compose écrit et chante et
compte bien enregistrer un
album devant une t envie de réussir le
Conseil général a décidé de soutenir
Elvina notamment dans l'accomplissement
de ses projets musicaux une aide
exceptionnelle pour un parcours
admirable qui va lui permettre
d'enregistrer son premier album la
présidente du conseil général Nassim
Dindar a tenu à rencontrer en personne
la jeune Elvina nous on est fier de toi
et la réunion doit êtreier de toi il
faut trouver le bon canal après pour que
tout ce que tu as
fait
soit soit vu en
exemplarité a seulement 18 ans atteint
d'un handicap sévère Elvina avance
chaque jour dans la bonne direction et
d'une manière exemplaire ses ambitions
et ses actions font de cette jeune fille
un modèle pour les personnes handicapées
mais aussi pour tous les Réunionnais
c'est une enfant qui est battante qui a
envie de s'accrocher et là quand je
vois au niveau où maintenant voilà je
suis
fierre retrouver Elvina dimanche 24
février au jardin de l'État pour la
journée départementale du
handicap le Conseil Général de la
Réunion vous a présenté lien social le
Conseil général au côté des
Réunionnais